they made me feel like I was a gang
member pretty much and they wanted to
talk him into every single one of my
tattoos arm Balthasar's poised for
action
what kind of hardened bugs could they be
after I didn't know whether it was a
bank robbery or there was a serial
killer loose the way that they in from
it like that
turns out the officers were targeting
not robbers or killers but strippers ten
officers rated a cheetah's gentlemen's
club in Kearny Mesa California to bust
any unlicensed dancers we're I'm a bad
girl that so committed they were that
they devoted more than two hours to
meticulously documenting the ladies and
their paperwork conducting random
inspections of strip clubs is one
responsibility of the San Diego Police
Department's Vice unit says the
department spokesman photographs of the
entertainer's permit and the person in
possession of it are taken for
investigative purposes but come on no
cops have better things to do
san Diego's police chief recently
stepped down amid a variety of sex crime
scandals involving his officers
including Christopher Hayes who was
arrested for groping and illegally
detaining women in Anthony Arabella's
who is now serving time for his habit of
demanding sexual favors from women he
pulled over for drunk driving seems like
there are bigger threats within San
Diego PD than inside any strip joint so
maybe the vice squad cops could forget
about strip clubs and spend more time
patrolling the halls of their own
department
next stop Spearmint Rhino follies show
on Twitter submit your nominees for next
month and check out Chris Nordby this
month's featured follower the bigshot
tweeter in me are you tweeting me